Speaker 1: Donald Trump has been found liable of
sexual abuse and defamation of E! Jean Carroll.
He has not been found liable when it comes to
rape. Why am I using the term liable? I'm using
the term liable because this is a civil lawsuit.
And Trump indeed. These are not criminal charges.
Trump will has been ordered to pay $5 million
in damages. This is a major story we've been
following for some time. E Jean Carroll, a writer,
alleges that alleged and alleges that Donald Trump
sexually assaulted and raped her in the Bergdorf
Goodman Department store in Manhattan in New York
City in the nineties. The reason let me even
before I go further. Donald Trump, in denying
those accusations, insulted her in a number
of different ways due to a special provision
that allows you to bring a civil suit in cases of
sexual assault, even when the criminal aspect has
passed that statute of limitations. Eugene Carroll
was able to sue Trump civilly in New York, both
for sexual assault and for defamation, and she
has prevailed. We can say CNN reports a manhattan
federal jury found that Donald Trump sexually
abused Jean Carroll in a luxury department
store dressing room in the spring of 1996 and
awarded her $5 million for battery and defamation.
Carroll alleged Trump raped her in the Bergdorf
Goodman Department store and then defamed her when
he denied her claim, saying she's not his type
and suggested she made up the story to boost book
sales. Trump denied all wrongdoing. He does not
face jail time as a result of the civil verdict.
While the jury did find that Trump sexually abused
her sufficient to hold him liable for battery. The
jury did not find that Carroll proved he raped
her. So there's a bunch of different stories that
are going on here. One of the stories is Trump's
lawyer and other maggots saying Trump prevailed.
He was not found liable for rape. That's one
perspective. The other perspective is Trump
did not prevail. He's been ordered
to pay $5 million for sexual assault
and for defamation, and he certainly did not
prevail. The other perspective and we'll look
at Trump's response is that this is all just the
same politically organized weaponization of law
enforcement, that a lot of them that they've been
saying now for years. There's no evidence of that
whatsoever. Everything here was handled based on
every lawyer I spoke to this morning. Everything
was handled perfectly by the judge, despite
Trump's allegations that the judge has it out
for Trump in some way. Now, there is the belief
that there will be an appeal here. Trump's lawyer.
Tacopina, Is it? Joe Tacopina said that they will
appeal and again restated that Trump prevailed in
the sense that he was not found liable for rape.
But the outcome is still quite bad for Trump.
Will Trump pay the $5 million? Well, we don't
know. Certainly not before any relevant appeals
have concluded that we can be sure of. If Trump
ultimately does pay. Maybe he can do some of the
things he's done in the past, like maybe reroute
$5 million in, I don't know, campaign donations
to pay for this or something along those lines.
The MAGA people are already dismissing this as
less than it's simply a civil case. This isn't
criminal. It's no big deal. As if suddenly civil
cases are completely irrelevant. But of course we
know that that's not the case. After the break,
we are going to look at the complete crumbling
of Trump in response to this, as well as a former
Trump White House staffer coming forward and
saying there were countless allegations of sexual
harassment against Trump while he was president
of the United States. Forget about the dozens
of allegations against Trump before he became
president. It turns out that there are dozens
of allegations against Trump while he was in the
White House. We just learned about this in the
last 24 hours. Incredible, but not surprising.
We will talk about that after the break.